J'ouvre mon entreprise...
Pour le plaisir d'être entrepreneur...
Et d'innover !
De plaire à Macron !
Ah ça je m'en bats les couilles en vrai.
Aujourd'hui les amis on va créer une startup
et ouvrir
un réseau social.
Et crois-moi on y arrivera, on atteindra nos rêves, on les touchera du bout des doigts.
Allez c'est parti.
O.K. on y va nouvelle partie pour commencer entrez le nom de votre entreprise ci-dessous.
[Bruits de clavier.]
Balékouille.
Ah j'suis un requin dans le business sa mère !
"Vous avez reçu un nouvel email."
Déjà ?
Attendez, là je viens d'ouvrir la startup, arrêtez.
Si l'administration m'assassine avant même que j'ai ouvert.
Arrêtez s'il-vous-plaît.
Tu sens le vécu ou pas ? *Rires*
Alors "prêts" oh il faut faire un prêt à la banque "Eazy Money".
C'est la banque de Booba apparemment. *Musique : Easy money *
Montant 40 000 dollars...
30% d’intérêts ?!
Mec c'est abusé les banques actuellement
quand tu fais un crédit c'est entre 1 et 3%.
Je me suis renseigné hein. *Rire*
Mec c'est abusé je dois leur rendre 46 700.
Aller j'suis endetté, c'est parti !
Nous sommes dans nos bureaux, putain ils sont beaux...
NULS, ils sont nuls, ils sont complètement nuls.
Attends je check mes e-mails j'ai reçu un e-mail.
Félicitations pour votre nouvel emprunt.
La banque a accepté de prêter de l'argent
à une entreprise qui s'appelle Balékouille.
Je respecte ça vraiment.
Objectif : Première chose, aller dans l'onglet "finances" et prenez un prêt. OK.
Engagez un directeur des ventes pour générer des contrats. Pas OK.
Alors "Employés", "Recrutement", "Chef des ventes".
Ok ! On va chercher un "Chef des ventes". C'est parti !
Un nouveau candidat a été trouvé, oh putain. 98%, oh t'es nul !
T'es nul, dégage ! Tu peux être chef des ventes à Monoprix.
Mais clairement pas à Balékouille & co.
88% ! En plus d'avoir un prénom de merde il est complètement nul ! C'est incroyable.
Oh c'est facile les blagues sur les prénoms hein !
Bon la meilleure c'est elle hein, 144% hein. Elle coûte un max de tunes ! putain !
Ok je l'embauche, vas-y, perdons pas de temps. On veut la meilleure des meilleures !
Faut qu'on crée un produit, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Mec, un service d'hébergement de vidéos,
c'est pas comme si il y avait de la concurrence en plus...
On peut le faire, on va s'appeler "TonTube". Mec j'suis inspiré c'est fou, j'suis visionnaire tu verras.
"Page de destination", "Développement".
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut ? J'comprends pas, j'comprends pas, j'comprends pas !
Ok, donc il me faut un développeur ! Il faudrait peut-être qu'on mette des...
aménager un peu ce truc là.
Pc, écran, chaise, clavier, souris, bureau, pour 3 000$ ! Enfin un truc qui coûte "pas cher" !
Ok on en met un, et ensuite on en met un 2ème parce qu'on va avoir un petit développeur qui va se ramener,
et on va les coller ! Parce qu'on veut qu'ils s'entendent bien !
Alors candidats, candidats. Elle est efficace et pas chère. C'est la Maaf cette meuf ?
On la prend ! J'ai pris 2 meufs ! Aaahh ! L'égalité des sexes ! Où sont les homministes ?!
Alors statistiques, voilà. Donc là, on peut la faire rechercher des modules qui vont nous permettre
de créer notre logiciel.
On va prendre heu.. C'est quoi qu'il fallait comme module ?
Composant UI, c'est là. 1 000$. Ah !
Il en a pour 2h. Ça va il va aller vite,
et ensuite on mettra un composant Backend. Ok, et ensuite c'était un composant Module d'interface.
Et elle vient bosser ou pas l'autre pute là ! Putain !
Pardon excusez-moi, j'commence déjà à traiter mes employés c'est chaud.
Ok 'est bon ils bossent ! Ça se sort les doigts du cul ! On va pouvoir officiellement lancer TonTube,
LA nouvelle plateforme qui hébergera les plus grande stars du net de demain ! Mais demain.
"2 modules pour Kwitch ; Prix fixé : 1 600$ ; Urgence moyenne ; 8h de production", j'accepte,
j'm'en bats les couilles il me faut de l'argent j'accepte tout !
Faut qu'je reprenne un développeur, allez j'prends un dév.. Nan attends attends.
A chaque fois je m'enflamme et mon entreprise elle coule. On va attendre.
Nan j'attends pas vas-y.
Est-ce qu'on peut livrer le contrat ? On empoche 1 600$, ça a été fait en 2-2-2, allez j'cherche un autre contrat.
Donc pour résumer là, j'passe mon temps à trouver des contrats,
c'est des entreprises qui m'achètent des composants.
Eux, ils créent les composants. Voilà c'est tout ce qu'il se passe.
Par exemple là Backend il lui en faut hein.
Du coup j'clique sur cet esclave... Cet employé pardon !
Et j'lance la création du Backend.
Le problème en fait pour TonTube c'est qu'il faut que je trouve,
un module d'interface, et j'ai pas ça, ça n'existe pas.
3 modules !
Allez ! Vas-y c'est quoi les modules ?
Il faut des "Composant UI" !
Vas-y je te les fais.
*MUSIQUE*
Je ne comprends pas.
Mes développeurs sont incompétents.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi très rapidement.
En gros, ils peuvent produire des modules.
Tous ces modules-là ! Je m'en bats les steaks, mon gars !
Mais à 100% !
Là, par exemple, j'ai une commande.
Il me faut ça ! Un "Composant de Wireframe".
Ok !
Mais le "Composant de Wireframe",
ils peuvent pas le faire !
Voilà ! Je p-peux pas le créer puisque ce n'est pas dans leurs compétences !
Pour TonTube, le truc module d'interface pareil ce n'est pas dans leurs compétences
Je fais comment moi ?
Oh putain ! 1980$ Parce que c'est une urgence critique ! Pour seulement 2 modules !
J'ai bien fait d'être entrepreneur
En plus j'ai déjà produit ce qu'il lui faut parce que je fais ça en avance. BIM !
Allez c'est payer on en parle plus *sifflements*
Ok, on a atteint le Tier 3 ! Au niveau 5 on pourra recruter des mecs plus compétents ...
Regardez, l'argent remonte c'est fou on va pouvoir atteindre le niveau 5
et avoir un manager et tout là
(voix de beauf ) : Eh la Silicon Valley à coté c'est du pain d'épices
Mais il est en retard la mec, il arrive à 9h30 !
T'es en retard là ! Comment je fais pour le démolir ? Regardez ses horaires c'est marqué là
9h-17h bon je me suis peut-être énervé pour rien je pensais qu'il commençait à 7 heures
J'avoue pardon excuses moi
Par contre t'as vu il a baissé en productivité de malade, va falloir que je les vire et que j'en prennes d'autres sans pitié
Ouais je vais faire ça j'en ai absolument rien à foutre.
Attend c'est abusé, lui c'est vraiment un enculé
Il est entrain de faire le composant base de donnée, regarde la barre
Où elle en est mon gars. il lui rester une ligne de code à faire, même pas même pas, un caractère
Il faisait *appuie sur une touche* . C'est bon, c’était créer. Le mec, il part avant de finir
Il me met en retard dans ma livraison, putain, mais quel espèce de petit enculé
Alors lui, lui il va dégager lui! Ça fait 2 semaines que l'entreprise existe, OK
On est à 25 000  dollars, on survie hein, vraiment on survie ! Urgence critique
4 600 dollars
*MUSIQUE RELIGIEUSE*
Oh putain, Travaillez esclaves ! Travaillez ! *bruit de fouet*
Roh ils bossent comme des chiens, mec ils ont mal aux bras
A force de taper sur le clavier, c'est un gros contrat, allez donner vous putain
Qu'il est lent, mais c'est pas possible, il a appris à coder en école de menuiserie
Ou quoi lui,  non mais c'est dingue. Aller je livre, aboule la tune
Quoi 3 heures de retard, c'est 900 dollars de moins
Sur 4 600 ! Alors là mon pote, tu sais quoi, on va faire "employé"
Oh mais il y a un manager, putain je peux prendre un manager ! Le manager dirige tout type d'employés
Les managers donnent aux employés un bonus de vitesse. Ah ben voilà c'est ça qu'il nous fauuuut ! Pour les
Pour les booster un peu ! Mon manager j’espère que ça sera David Douiller
Mon gars, et ouais j'ai sorti le blaze d'un mec très vieux *Rire*
T'es pas mal toi Sarah Robbins, je t'aime bien. Encore une femme très bien ça
Non mais là ils n’arrivent plus à bosser du tout. Regarde ça va à 2 à l'heure. Quoi, vous avez reçu un e-mail
Nelle Weber, j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle. Bonjour, j'ai été vraiment très heureux de travailler ici à balékouille
Malheureusement, j'ai récemment ressenti que l'entreprise et mes objectifs
sont très différent l'un de l'autre. je démissionne de mon poste de chef des ventes
Bonne continuation, Nelle Weber
Ben tu sais quoi, bats les couilles tant mieux, de toute façon je voulais te virer. j'aurais pas à
payer des indemnités chômage AHAHA tiens ! J'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
Oh non putain! Bonjour, j'ai été vraiment très heureux de travailler.. laisse moi deviner
Malheureusement j'ai récemment vu que
que les objectifs de l'entreprise et les miens étaient différents  blabla
J'ai récemment ressenti que l'entreprise et mes objectifs sont très différent l'un de l'autre
*APPLAUDISSEMENT*
Va travailler le bois un peu, parce que je te jure que tu n'as pas fait une école  de DEF c'est impossible
Aller ! Supprimer ça dégage
OHlala comme elle est efficace putain !
J'ai trop bien fait de la prendre.
Tout le monde crée ses petits composants
Putain mec on commence à être un vrai patron, c'est beau !
Urgence critique : 5 200 !
Oh la la j'vais être riche.
"Félicitation !"
"Vous avez atteint le niveau 4 : nouveau chef d'employé"
Chef développeur :
Chef Développeur s'occupe de fusionner les composants en modules.
On va pouvoir créer notre réseau social mais avant...
Il faut qu'on amasse un maximum de thune
sinon la clé ira sous la porte.
Bon écoutez j'suis un bon patron,
je vois que cet employé est fatigué,
il en a marre de coder
Qu'est ce que je fais, je l'envoie en vacances.
Nouveau contrat...
4 composant UI
Bon je l'enverrai en vacances juste un peu plus tard, ça va !
*MUSIQUE*
hopla ! c'est livré, c'est fait, n'en parlons pluuuuuuuuuuuuus
Bon maintenant écoute tu as bien travaillé
Tu peux aller en vacances.
envole toi comme un oiseau
Mec c'est long d'évoluer sa mère
en fait je préfère être caissier.
Oh mon dieu un contrat.
"Urgence critique !"
7 200 !!! Wouuww on y va !!!!
Et dire que j'voulais être caissier y'a deux minutes.
BIM, 7 200 dollars !
'Tain elle revient quand de vacances,
elle est partie 8 mois ou quoi !
Elle fait quoi, elle fait un tour du monde ? C'est quoi ce délire là.
EEEHH Re !
Alors tes vacances c'était bien ?
t'as la forme maintenant j'parie hein ?!
Fatique : 5,6%
MAIS TU REVIENS DE VACANCES !
Nouveau avantages débloqués : boissons gratuites.
"Augmentez la satisfaction des employés en leur offrant un accès gratuit au distributeur."
Mais vous payez comme tout le monde mec !
Les pièces de 20 centimes toi même tu sais.
Bon mec à un moment faut arrêter les conneries.
J'fais le mec, j'vais en mettre.
J'vais mettre une plante ici, un distributeur...
Si j'fais faillite c'est 100% à cause de ça.
Ce qui nous faut c'est totalement un Chercheur Développeur !
Pour pouvoir faire des modules et ouvrir notre réseau social !
"Enchériré, WHAT ?
"Vous allez être en compétition avec les autre entreprises pour remporter ce contrat."
"Sélectionnez le prix désiré par heure."
OWW SHIT !
Nan on va se mettre à 220, sinon on l'aura pas.
Et on l'a pas eu ! SuperstarDevs nous l'a volé pour 3.900 dollars.
Fils de pute !
Eh moi j'vends pas mon cul, j'baisse pas les prix. J'm'en bats les couilles.
Urgence critique ! Ok.
Réflechissons bien, 28 heures.
En plus on a juste à faire ça, mec c'est easy à faire.
350 par heure, ça c'est bien ça, on gagne.
OH LA LA LA LA ON AURAIT PU METTRE PLUS MERDE !
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave, c'est pas grave.
C'est très bien, c'est très bien, c'est très bien.
C'est hyper grave, mais c'est pas grave.
Meec on a 62 000 dollars de trésoreries.
ATTENDEZ, on va refuser tous les contrats on va faire notre réseau social !
"AdopteUneBlague"
C'est hyper marrant ça va cartonner,
Le principe c'est : les gens poste une balgue, et t'en choisi une.
Et il se passe rien parce qu'il ya un problème dans le concept.
J'suis entrain de construire les modules pour pouvoir faire ce qu'il faut.
C'EST CHAUD.
Mec, adopte une blague : implémenter.
*0*
"Toutes les fonctionnalités ont été correctement implémentés. Cliquez sur le bouton en dessous... pour la mise en ligne !"
Frais d'hébergement : 375$/ jour
Revenu total : 0$
NAN MAIS C'EST UN SKETCH ?!
Amélioration, comment j'fais ?
Putain, l'nombre de modules qu'y faut ! Nan mais y ont fumer !
Bonjour, nous avons actuellement 362 utilisateurs
sur AdopteUneBlague, ça cartonne. On gagne 10 dollars par jour
YEP, putain mais mec, c'est fou ce jeu, je suis addict à 100%
AdopteUneBlague a généré 14 dollars de revenu, on peut se payer un Macdo grâce à notre
réseau social c'est incroyable, oh la la mais il va grandir vous allez voir c'est notre bébé
On va le faire mûrir, regardez la courbe, revenu  21 dollars
258 utilisateurs sur le web et 412 sur mobile
On va l'améliorer
*MUSIQUE*
AdopteUneBlague a généré 218,21 dollars de revenu !
Objectif atteint !
C'est à peu près ce que Mark Zuckerberg, créateur de Facebook gagne.. chaque seconde LOL
Les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo et de cette startup
J’espère que ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si c'est le cas, pas la startup, la vidéo
Finalement avoir une startup c'est un peu être baby-sitter
Mais pour des adultes,
N’hésitez pas à aller vous créer un compte sur AdopteUneBlague, ça me fera vraiment plaisir *RIRE*
Ça me permettra de payer ces gens qui
Travaillent face à un mur tous, c'est horrible, j'aurais pu les mettre face à face
Mais non je suis un FDP
Allez portez-vous bien. A bientôt !